networking it's the way computers
exchange information around the world
and just like the burrito its
architecture is abstracted into seven
layers based on the open systems
interconnection model
at the bottom we have physical hardware
like fiber optic cables that literally
carry light from point a to point b
somehow this light travels all the way
to layer seven where it can be
transmitted directly into your
consciousness in the form of pixels on a
screen or vibrations from a speaker
that's exactly what you're doing right
now as an end user accessing this video
over the hypertext transfer protocol
in addition to http there are many other
protocols at layer 7
like smpt for email or ftp for file
transfers
now let's work our way backwards to
understand how we got here layer 6
is the presentation layer and
essentially it works as a translator to
ensure that a stream of bits from a
computer
like a jpeg image is encoded to a
standard format that can be used at the
application layer
below that we have the session layer
which is responsible for managing the
connection between two computers
it's here we have things like user
authentication and authorization
to control whether or not a user has
access to data on a server
we've all been on a zoom call where some
random person joins and shares their
unsolicited artwork they manage to
authenticate on zoom servers by
exploiting layer 5
and that brings us to the middle of the
stack the transport layer
the transmission control protocol or tcp
is the foundation for
pretty much everything we've looked at
so far its job is to take a stream of
data from one computer
and transfer it to another it determines
how to segment the data into smaller
pieces that can be sent over the network
in the correct order
it receives the data from layer 4 the
network layer in the form of packets
it's here we find the internet protocol
every computer connected to the network
has its own unique ip address
which identifies that computer and
whenever it sends information over the
network
it does so in the form of an ip packet
that contains that address in the header
a packet is just a unit of data along
with some information about who sent it
this happens from a router or gateway
which connects to layer two
the data link and its role is to connect
one physical node in the network to
another via protocols like ethernet or
wi-fi
and that is how over 2.5 quintillion
bytes of data are shared around the
world every single day
this has been networking in 100 seconds
if you want to see more short videos
like this please like and subscribe
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one and now a quick word
from our sponsor
taco bell seven layer burritos just 99
cents